nadia and valentin remember a better
life
a life before fighting started between
russian-backed separatists
and ukrainian army in the east seven
years ago
before their village of chiramalik
became a front line
in a conflict often described as a
battle between moscow
and the west the situation has been
calmer in the last couple of years but a
recent escalation of fighting
was a reminder of the risks they face
the separatists control the land across
the river
the army says there are sniper and
machine gun positions among the trees
few people go down to the bank on this
side anymore
it's dangerous to go there because
nobody knows from where the shooting
will start
it's quiet now but we are almost as
afraid of the quiet as we are of the
shelling
when it starts the shells fly over and
you don't know where to hide
the ukrainian army keeps a low profile
in the village but has occupied many of
the homes abandoned by families
who fled the violence many of the
surrounding fields are mined
nobody can go to the cemetery because
separatist snipers and ukrainian
soldiers are close by
valentin thinks his parents gravestones
have been damaged by the fighting
he misses life before the war
we used to go hunting i used to breed
sheep i can't do this now because of the
minefields or because the military stop
us
i had to kill most of our animals
because i can't afford their food
it's our easter soon and we hope the
army will let us visit the cemetery
but we don't know russia says it's
pulling back its forces from the
ukrainian borders after what it
describes
as military exercises but there is still
no sign of any breakthrough in
negotiations
towards a lasting political settlement
seven years of failed ceasefires and
negotiations
kiev blames moscow for making what it
describes as unrealistic
demands we also have our ad red lines
uh which we couldn't cross because the
russians would like
uh to misuse this format also to
to bring us to the table of negotiations
with the occupied territories for
example
uh or try to federalize ukraine or
actually try to control ukraine via
these occupied territories
it couldn't be accepted by any
government here in this country nadia
and valentin say the risk of a sudden
escalation in fighting means their five
children
rarely visit them anymore life used to
be beautiful and fun
they say but everything is so uncertain
now john stratford al jazeera chirmalik
eastern ukraine